so everyone's saying that they hate the
cooking I'm not helping your case here I
think whoever did this heinous crime
didn't have the time to that it was
obviously a crime of passion
that is a noted lie hi I'm P I John I've
been a private investigator in Los
Angeles for about two-and-a-half years
and today I'm on possibly the most
important assignment of my life deducing
who ate the cookie I don't know how this
is gonna go I'm now going to close my
eyes okay when is this fiasco over with
I can open my eyes yeah okay I know all
right well why don't you come up and
join me here what's your name
Jasmine Jasmine would you have for
breakfast my roommates mom is here from
China right now so she made vows so I
had a bow oh is that those um those like
sort of dough lumps with like jelly
filling and stuff in the middle or are
they like pseudo dumplings what they're
steamed buns with like meat pork filling
in there okay we're describing the same
thing just in different ways okay yeah
they're I mean gonna say it's like akin
to a dumpling sort of isn't completely
wrong right okay so I so I was right
okay all right so you had Bao this
morning yeah okay how many one and then
a different thing called a being Oh
what's it Bing it's like a flattened
dough okay yeah you take the same dough
and you flatten it and then you can fry
it
oh just the dough yeah and then I came
in and ate the cookies gone I might come
into play later we deliver Oh
Gower in sunset you walk to work no I
don't because I work out in the morning
so I'm like in a rush to get to work so
I Drive we like to do at the gym
I take hate classes okay how long are
those an hour an hour of hit mm-hmm
Wow how often you go to hit class every
day every day yes what's your favorite
dessert bobba bobba where you from not
counting calling you been out here 12
years why'd you eat the cookie cuz I
like cookies okay you can return the
lineup for now thank you you look very
nervous why don't you come down here
what's your name
destiny destiny how was it the cookie
yeah delicious
okay so everyone's saying that they mate
the cookie where are you from
no it's Airy everywhere nowhere evasive
where do you live now Hollywood East
Hollywood face it again what's your
favorite kind of food can I say
breakfast sure but now we got to dig
into that mmm what kind of breakfast all
of it I'm not helping your case here
you're not helping your case yeah
that's three evasive answers in a row
you have to get more specific so let's
start with eggs do you do eggs for
breakfast you okay omelette scrambled
I've recently discovered the runny egg
that's weird
I know but it's good nah you should
undiscovered that cereal mm-hmm favorite
cereal milk doesn't really say right hmm
would you say you're anti milk no not
okay but milk doesn't sit right you say
not in a full bowl not in a full bowl
yeah cuz you're gonna have milk with you
cereal you're right
do you ever drink any nut based dairy
substitute beverages I have it is good
do you put that on your cereal I've had
it before I have steered away from it
how does that sit it's too sweet to know
ethereal what's your favorite dessert
can I say my mama's chocolate chip
cookies sure I'm sure they're fantastic
no offense to your mama
one I just don't buy it are they're my
favorite no I don't think that answer is
legit I think you want me to think
you're a cookie person that I am a picky
person I'm sorry are you a liar yes I
think in general you're very very
untrustworthy mmm but I don't think you
ate the cookie but that's not an
official verdict okay anyway this has
been wonderful thanks for your time you
can return up how about you please a
little this is a real meeting of the
minds here we've circled each other for
years well
dual stars and here we are our gravity
drawing us ever closer what's your
favorite food from Remy so what's your
favorite type of shrimp dish straight-up
shrimp cocktail shrimp cocktail why do
you think that is why did you follow
with shrimp mmm when I was a kid
particular experience or a restaurant
there was a all-you-can-eat buffet at
this one place that my parents were on
vacation and I would just sit there and
just eat an entire bowl of shrimp
what about baking when I enjoy baking
I'm not a baker you know okay what's
your favorite baked treat I don't
believe that I feel like you've calmed
down a little bit since you sat down
I'm were these more at ease yeah
interesting posture he thinks that he's
got I think we've all got me
I know oh man okay I I think I'm done
for now Kevin I'll probably need more
from you later the shrimp cocktail
really threw me for a loop I don't know
how they always know navigate my way out
of that so how about you could you come
join me please sure what's your name
Mitch Mitch what's up where you from
Whittier California where do you live
now
same place you commute in mm-hmm where
you work what do you do here I'm a
social media strategist what's your
favorite food steak
what kind of here are you like a steak a
guy you know the cuts medium-rare
anybody that's a well-done is crazy
you'd probably get a well-done Wow Mitch
from Whittier tea attitude what's your
favorite dessert tiramisu
Terry soon sorry tiramisu in Milan okay
okay you say you're in social media here
yes okay yes so what's that entail
we pretty much analyze how well in love
it is dude how are the videos with me
doing pretty bad that's a lie pretty
better that is a noted lie I need you
down here please what's your name Kirby
Kirby how was the cookie it was pretty
good
that's actually a pretty good way to
describe on the lot oh yeah yeah a
little too crunchy too crunchy okay what
kind of cookies do you like I like fresh
out of the oven half baked chocolate
chip oh really aren't you worried about
like Salmonella or
the lie it's a myth this took a
dangerous turn into misinformation land
but all right so what's your favorite
kind of cookie challenge oh okay where
you from originally I'm from your LAX
and now I live in Culver City what's
very time for type of food anything with
cheese
okay very broad food answers here for
many people cheese let's get a little
bit more specific mac and cheese mac and
cheese okay oh so you you're you're kind
of running a risk of ever eating mac and
cheese huh how did you make mac and
cheese with like almond milk you tried
okay sweet or savory Phoebe favorite ice
cream flavor could be line there's no
salt and mallanna's you add salt I think
whoever did this heinous crime didn't
have the time for that
it was obviously a crime of passion no I
keep us all back in the pocket something
that's weird um okay Kirby I'd rather
spend more time in here and with you and
go down this cheese rabbit hole but
again if that's good stuff back on the
line and my my last subject what's your
name Brian Brian
where you from Kansas City Missouri or
Kansas side was eerie okay thank you for
asking
sure well don't ask I know and I always
need people to know how much I know I'm
smart how long you lived out here three
years
I'm where'd he work husband what do you
do here video producer where do you live
sally village what's your favorite type
of food I'm gonna bait to I really don't
I just like food in general so it's like
not I will eat whatever you put that
answer sucks top five top five top five
if I just like I'm rambling things I'm
gonna say Pat see you I'm gonna say red
velvet cake I'm gonna say waffles I love
chicken tenders and the new popeyes
chicken sandwich it's fantastic do we
have to hashtag this ad that was
answered okay I think you mentioned like
a Thai dish first right see you yeah
that's you okay and then red velvet cake
chicken sandwich what else wasn't that
that so Jenner I really will eat just
about anything favorite ice cream flavor
cookies and cream ooh cookie dough
actually cookie dough that's better
cookies yeah
oh I should have looked at this first
what a weird bite that got taken out of
this I don't think you should talk about
my teeth rookie mistake I should have
investigated the the evidence first all
right well I guess I gotta I gotta come
to a conclusion here Ryan thank you
sorry we couldn't speak more Jasmine
could you come here please so I need you
to explain to me the difference between
a bow and a ding okay
a bow is they're kind of the same
structure fundamentally um when you have
a bow you roll it so that the bottom
like the center is still pretty thick
you have a filling I like the meat
filling what kind of meat what what's
your favorite meat probably be so you
like pork in the bow the flavors just
mesh well because you add like garlic
ginger you just like pigs or hogs
no I'm actually you're the pig anyway Oh
Mitch make a bigger sure watch very
movie understood by what's your favorite
comedy - interesting
all right it's all I got thanks Mitch
all right I think the person who ate
this cookie came from this half of the
lineup jasmine or Mitch or Ryan I have
written down here lie under Mitch's name
oh it's because Mitch was not making a
lot of eye contact with me I called
Jasmine back one last time because I
wanted to try to get her to laugh
because whoever ate this cookie was
laughing I'm just gonna say Jasmine I
think Jasmine gave the cookie
oh oh we got her he got her oh thank you
for your time Mitch hey man nothing but
love man oh wow
[Applause]
[Music]